Djibouti ambuli Airport
the Beating Heart of an International
Rescue Mission
planes landing and departing all day
carrying traumatized civilians away from
Bloodshed and back to safety this
Italian military plane has 75 foreign
Nationals on board that they managed to
evacuate from Sudan they brought them
here refueled taken a moment and now
they're taking them to Safety in Europe
thousands of UK Nationals are currently
stranded in war towards Sudan after one
evacuation Mission only rescued
diplomatic staff now a British military
presence is building in Port Sudan to
plan for potential evacuations but many
feel it's too little too late
what was happening was that this war was
getting more and more intense
it was like a someone turned the volume
knob up literally every day went up
another another notch another notch
another notch I had a front view
perspective of this going on right in
front of my apartment
Jonathan was only living in Horton for
four months when warbro count he's now
one step closer to home thanks to a
French evacuation flight
by now it's six seven days into the
conflict and you're thinking come on
come on
what's what's our government going to do
for us
same message comes through sit tight
sit tight
they're still being told today
to sit tight
as Brits trapped in Khartoum they must
be asking themselves why have we been
left
Road from him Sudanese Irish family sit
in a State of Shock happy to be safe but
devastated to be torn apart
Sarah left behind her husband and
father-in-law to get her three kids to
safety it's really difficult
[Music]
but we're happy we're here now and we
got out anyways but there's a lot of
virus Irish citizens still there like
can you tell me a little bit about what
the experience was like for you when the
fighting was bad it was scary because
all of us we had to sleep on the floor
and we were scared of bullets coming in
and then one time you're all sitting in
the sitting room and we are like we were
relaxed we were watching TV a
documentary
and they hit our we fought a bullet air
our window or a bomb because our Windows
started shaking and and it was so loud
and it scared us
another plane lands from Sudan This Time
commandeered by Swedish military
more relief from more civilians and none
of them British